the world's climate scientists have
issued their starkest warning yet about
the speed and impact of human-caused
global warming it's a landmark u.n
report out this morning
and it warns that there will be many
more disasters like this summer's
historic flooding in europe and
elsewhere
if countries don't slash greenhouse gas
emissions now
roxanna saberi is in london with more on
the report that the
u.n chief calls code red for humanity
roxanne when you think about the
usually muted language of science they
really didn't hold back here did they
that's right tony the report is sobering
it says our emissions are
warming the world fast and is certain to
keep warming in the coming decades
but just how hot and how dire the
disasters get
depend on how we act now
from fires like those that have been
raging across greece and
turkey to flooding and heat waves and
drought in the u.s
the u.n report says global warming is
rapidly hitting
every region of the world in
unprecedented ways
and it's unequivocal that we are to
blame
with global carbon emissions higher than
at any time in at least
two million years we are responsible for
it
yuri rogel is a senior author of the
report how alarmed should we be
we are not yet on track on a track to
even
stop this warming from further
increasing so yes we should be alarmed
also alarming the report finds that
melting ice sheets and sea level rise
caused by global warming
are irreversible for centuries to
millennia
even if we limit our emissions today the
scientists point out we've already made
the world nearly two degrees hotter than
pre-industrial levels
and if it warms another roughly two
degrees the upper target set by the 2015
paris climate treaty
every region will feel the heat much
more intensely
the scientists warned the world could
get there and beyond
this century unless we drastically cut
our carbon
methane and other greenhouse gas
emissions now
is it too late to act it is never too
late
every bit of warming that we can avoid
will be beneficial to us
acting together is absolutely necessary
in a global way
this challenge can really be overcome
the report was approved by
every country in the world it's sure to
push governments to commit to cutting
emissions faster
ahead of a big u.n climate summit in
scotland this fall
vlad roxy banner roxanna saberi in
london thank you very much
it's it's not too late but the warning
is dire
it is dire i mean what roxanna said
there at the very end is very important
the
the governments of the world have signed
off on this report so it's not just
scientist speaking it's official
speaking saying we all agree now
it's time to act and by the way we have
about a a 10-year budget
of emissions before we go over the cliff
we talk about a landmark the cliff is
ahead in the land and if we don't make a
change in that next
10-year time frame it could be very very
bad for for example
baby eloise all of our children i would
say that's what i think about the future
i mean we'll be okay i think we
think about our children and our
children's children it's very scary
yeah and this report hasn't been out for
a couple of years so that's why it's
been
it's so stark roxanna again thank you
very much